hey this is press to
Walker here's a wonderful logic test
ABCDE e multiplied by 4 is equal to Ed
CBA in other words multiplying by four
reverses the order of the
digits each letter is a different digit
from 0 to 9 I want to thank everyone who
suggested the problem to me pause the
video if you'd like to give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
[Music]
problem we will get started by solving
for the letter
a notice that 30,000 * 4 is equal to
120,000 that's a six-digit result but we
need the result to be a figit result so
that means a has to be less than three
so a can be equal to 0 1 or 2 it is
allowed for a to be equal to 0 you can
have a leading zero there's nothing in
the rules that prohibit it so we need to
work through each
case now notice e * 4 is equal to a that
means a is an even number so a has to be
equal to 0 or two so let's eliminate the
possibility that a is equal to
zero we'll look at the times table for
four if a were equal to Z it would have
to be that e were equal to Z or E were
equal to
5 now we can't have e equal to zero
because a would be equal to Zer so we
would need to have e is equal to
5 but what would happen if e were equal
to 5 the largest number we could have is
0 9 8
75 multiply that by 4 we get
39,500 but we would need the result to
be at least 50,000 because e would be
the first digit of the result so we
can't have e is equal to 5 and a is
equal to zero the result would be too
small so we can eliminate that case and
a is equal to
two now let's look at the times table
for four again and we see that e * 4 is
equal to something ending in
2 so this could be 12 that would mean
that e is equal to 3 it could be 32 that
would mean e is equal to 8 so if e is
equal to 3 or
8 but now 20,000 * 4 is equal to
80,000 so we can't have e is equal to 3
because that would be too small so we
see that e has to be equal to
so now let's just put in a is equal to 2
and E is equal to
8 now the result 8 DC B2 that's a number
that has to be a multiple of four the
divisibility rule for four is that a
number is divisible by four if and only
if the last two digits is a number
that's a multiple of four so B2 as a
number has to be a multiple of four
so let's look at our times table for
four so we could have 12 we could have
32 that would mean b would be equal to 1
or
three but what would happen if B were
equal to 3 we would have 23,000 about
multiplied by 4 and that's equal to
92,000 but 92,000 is too large of a
number because we already know that e is
is equal to 8 and we need the result to
be something in the
80,000 so that means we can't have B is
equal to three we must have B is equal
to
1 so we're making very good progress
here let's put in B is equal to
1 we now have d8 multiplied 4 is some
number that ends in one two so let's
look at all of the
possibilities one case is 112
in that case D would be equal to two
then we have 312 in that case D would be
equal to 7 so D is either 2 or S but we
already have that a is equal to two so D
cannot be equal to two and that means D
is equal to
7 so now All That Remains is to solve
for the letter c and I think we can do
this algebraically very easily
the number we have is
2178 + 100 C we need to multiply this by
4 and that's equal to
8712 + 100 C we distribute the four and
then we simplify this
equation so we have 300 C is equal to
2,700 dividing both sides by 300 we get
C is equal to 9 so we figured out we
figured out a is equal to 2 e is equal
to 8 B is equal to 1 D is equal to 7 and
C is equal to 9 so let's just finally
put it in presentation form the number
is
2,978 multiplied 4 is equal to 87912srs
L made but what if we had made a mistake
wouldn't it be safer to check through
all of the
possibilities so how many possible
numbers can there be for ab bcde e well
a can have a total of 10 different
options because there are 10 digits from
0 to 9 once we set a value for a the
digit B can be any of the nine remaining
digits then C can be any of the eight
remaining digits D can be any of the
seven and E can be any of the six
remaining digits multiplying all these
options gives
3,240
possibilities this will be too tedious
to do by hand but with the help of
computers we can check the first option
for
ABCDE multiply it by four and we get a
result we can see if the digits of the
result are exactly the reverse of
ABCDE in this case it is
false we can then just run through all
of these different
[Music]
permutations we're going to see that
there is exactly one
solution this solution will be
2,978 then we just run through all the
remaining possibilities and we can
confirm that
2,978 is the unique solution to this
[Music]
puzzle what an amazing
result thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time
oh